bonjour sunai merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france alors on l'a vu sur
les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs messages haineux envers la
communauté asiatique plus
particulièrement la communauté chinoise
est ce que c'est un phénomène qui
existait avant le coc u19 ou est-ce que
ça s'est exacerbée depuis ce temps ce
phénomène qui existait avant déjà les
locaux vides ce 9 mai il ya eu en fait
un pic pendant les deux vagues du comité
note donc en février mars
en fait il ya eu des insultes des
crachats des oeufs des femmes qui se
fout le gifler réussi ce premier
première bague
ensuite la deuxième vague est apparue en
fait après la mort du président de la
république mercredi le soir de
l'annnonce du président d une série de
postes ont été ont été postées sur sur
notre twitter appelant justement à
tabasser à violenter des asiatiques
existeront de combler les postes sur les
réseaux sociaux
est ce qu'il ya une augmentation de la
violence vous vous la voyez au quotidien
alors nous on a reçu un témoignage d'une
dame d'un jeune qui s'est fait tabassé
jeudi ce jeudi après midi le lendemain
dont des ces postes dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris
on a eu aussi avant avant l'apparition
de ses potes une fin qui s'est fait qui
s'est fait agresser on s'est fait
insulter la chine toc
donc ce qui est aussi inquiétant c'est
le nombre de reconduites c'est à dire
que les postes il n'ya pas c'est pas un
seul rhdp il ya main entre beats entre
800 et diaby 138 et il ya aussi à 1400
like pour chaque poste qui ont été
postés donc c'est ça qui est inquiétant
et sammour
l'ampleur du phénomène alors la licra
saisir la justice pour que cesse ce en
tout cas ses appels à l'aide
est-ce que vous vous sentez soutenu ces
derniers temps de la part des
associations d'un côté puis des
politiques de l'autre
alors c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu
beaucoup de l'intervention des
politiques concernant ces postes pour
dénoncer ces postes en revanche on a eu
le soutien de beaucoup d'associations
qui nous ont sinon des océans c'est
pacistes on espère turquie la justice va
pouvoir à faire son travail je sais que
apparemment
l'un des auteurs de 7 8 a été identifié
donc on attend maintenant des nouvelles
nous on attend on appelle à tous les
asiatiques et même des noms asiatiques
ajustements posté à signaler sur pharos
de nouveaux petits qui peuvent
apparaître et on va créer une
association notre latine associations 1
une sorte de boîte à outils justement
pour aider pour les assister à porter
pas prolifique comment on fait pour
porter plainte
lorsqu'on est confronté à ce genre de
poste on a vu la haye la communauté
asiatique parfois dans certains
quartiers s'organisent et justement pour
se protéger est ce que la police est là
aussi pour pour vous protéger
alors nous on a organisé se passe pour
nous protéger c'est en fait ils vont
accompagner des personnes entre la
sortie du métro et les leur domicile
donc c'est juste une organisation qu'on
ne compte que l'on fait il s'agit pas du
tout d'une ministre comme pouvait croire
certains élus certains élus donc il
s'agit vraiment de protéger les citoyens
bien sûr la police est au courant elle
nous quand on a besoin on peut toujours
appeler la police et moi je j'appelle à
faire appel à la police
lorsqu'il ya le moindre incident est-ce
que vous vous sentez que là que la peur
et plus particulièrement présente
aujourd'hui dans la communauté asiatique
de france alors a peur je pense qu'il
faut la rassurer on a peur effectivement
mais on a peur aussi du coup vide on a
peur des violences
mais il faut quand même faire être
surtout vigilants
voilà il faut j'appelle être vraiment
vigilant personnellement c'est pas peur
mais j'appelle à tout le monde d'être
vigilants merci beaucoup soupçonnent
d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes sa porte par le
collectif sécurité pour tous merci
beaucoup